على حافه حياه تتارجح بين متلازمه الفقر
والمرض والموت والاستعمار ابصر ضيف النور
في الاطراف النائيه البعيده في بلده
العزيزيه جنوب الجزائر
[موسيقى]
ما فائده من التحدي والتطوع الى وطن بلا
استعمال
[موسيقى]
القريه بحث عن الحريه والتحرر ملبيا
النداء الثوره والكفاح لاجل الجزائر
يتامل ضيفي ازمات العالم مقلبا صفحات حروب
مضت وملفات الصراعات على يديه طويت حيث ما
كان ثمه امل بتوقيت نجاه لازمه هنا او
هناك
عطل التصوير كيف صحتك الان
اسبوع الحمد لله انك بخير
وهي منطقه ريف خالصه على بعد 100 كيلو متر
بالضبط عن الجزائر العاصمه جنوب الجزائر
العاصمه كانت منطقه اولها عدد سكانها قليل
ثانيا اييي منطقه فقيره ما كانت كثير ما
حدش محدش اراد انه يجي هناك
حلو يتحقق كان يحلم بان تتخرج من
الابتدائيه في حياته كيف اثر هذا الرحيل
على تكوين شخصيه الاخضر الابراهيميه
في نهايه
1944 كان واضح على انه ما بقاش ما بقاش
منت طويله هو ما تظن في يناير
طبعا تغير تغيرت الحياه يعني لما احنا
اضطرينا ان ننتقل لانه
اعمامي ما كانوش حابين انه
ارمله اخوهم تبقى وحدها مع اولاد صغار
فيها مكان نهائي
فانتقلنا الى مكان اسمه في رغباره هذه
كانت يعني قريه صغيره ويعني هناك اللي انا
اخذت الشهاده الابتدائيه
كريم جدا لكن بدايه الوقت لانه كان صارم
جدا هل حقا لا تذكر انه يعني كلمك ولو مره
واحده مثلا بطريقه هيك قريبه قال لك كلمه
رقيقه
ثلاث اسابيع على الاكثر قبل وفاته كان
شتاء
وكان يعني بعد العشاء كان يطلبني يعني
اجلس معه
هذه الفتره الوحيده اللي قعدت معه
طبعا هو اللي يتكلم مش انا انا استمع
فكلمني عن حياته وكلمني
بسبب المرض يعني
دورها محدود جدا
قرارها محدود جدا لكن
المرشد للنظره لانه كان عمرها ممكن 34 35
سنه
على اولادها معناها ما فكرتش انها
تتزوجنا
في السراء والضراء يعني نحنا مدينين ذهب
كثير
عليها ايام نصيب فقدت اربعه من اشقائك
انتهى البكر
حوالي 20 سنه بعد ما تزوجت فتره قصيره
يعني
طريقه عشائريه لا تختلف كثيرا اللي موجود
في المشرق
كبير العائله كان واحد اسمه الاخضر انا
انا غالبا مسمي عليه
كان همم كان شخصيه قويه جدا
وهو يعني وان كان مش هو اللي كان مسؤول
عليه رسميا يعني
لكن احترمني وكنت تقضي بعض الوقت عنده
طريق الكتاب
الى المدرسه فرنسا وه
نا طانيس الجزائر
يعني بوادر
سنه 45 لما الفرنساويين عملوا هذه المجازر
في
شرق الجزائر هنا الواحد بدا يشعر بانه
يعني في شيء مش مقبول
ثانيا كنا بنتابع بالضروره ما يجري في
تونس والمغرب كان في
كفاح مسلح
في البلد خلاص
ان الجسم الطلابي الجزائري في اوساط
الخمسينيات كان منقسم بين تسميتين او
هويتين الاتحاد العام للطلبه الجزائريين
او الاتحاد العام للطلبه المسلمين
الجزائريين فما السبب في الجزائر
كان عندنا تنظيم اسمه اتحاد طلبه شمال
افريقيا ما كانش فيه اتحاد الجزائر
الاخوان في تونس وفي المغرب
شكل
اتحادات وطنيه مغربيه محضه وتونسيه لحظه
في سنه
21 51 52 لكن شعرنا بانه لازم الان تتخلق
اتحاد الجزائر
وهنا الخلافه اللي حصل هو انه بين بعض
الاخوان كانوا يقولوا نسمي هذا الاتحاد
الاتحاد طلب الجزائري
واتجاه الاخر
اتحاد الطلبه المسلمين
طلبه المسلمين الجزائري
في خلق هذا الاتحاد
وبعدين المؤتمر الاول اللي تشكرت فيه
القياده تحياتي نائب رئيس الاتحاد مسؤول
عن الشغل
من كلامك جذور الحراك السياسيين
الابراهيمي بدات عند التحاق الطبي
بالجامعه الجزائر درست في الجامعه القانون
والعلوم السياسيه لكن ما كلام تكمل تعليمك
مثل ما انت قلت الى باريس عام
195 لماذا
العلوم السياسيه في باريس
له شهره واهميه اكبر بكثير من المعاهد
معاهد في اي مكان اخر ولا يزداد
ايضا هذا لانه محتاجين ناس في العاصمه
الفرنسيه
الاسباب الوطنيه
الاقي الحال حصل اني انا انتقلت بعد السنه
الاولى انتقلت الى باريس
وكنت ايامها نائب رئيس
الاتحاد طلب المسلمين الجزائريين مسؤول عن
الشؤون الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
عام
تفيء الاخضر الابراهيمي في ربيع شبابه
حالما بتحرر بلاده من الهيمنه والاستعمار
صوب عواصم الدول الصديقه قاصدا حشد الدعم
والتاييد لجبهه التحرير انطلق من القاهره
التي احب حتى اصبح ابنت ثورتها بالتبني
غصولا الى جاكرتا التي شكلت محطه مفصليه
في مسيره الابراهيميه السياسيه
اذا تمت محطه فاصله في تاريخ الجزائر وفي
مسارك السياسي عندما تم اختيارك قبل
الاتحاد الطلبات لتمثلهم في مؤتمر مهم في
اندونيسيا ما خلفيات هذا الاختيار واهميه
هذا المؤتمر
تاريخي كبير جدا
للدول المستقله في اسيا وافريقيا
طلبت اندونيسيا حبوا يعني
يحتفلوا بمرور سنه على هذا
الرقم بعقد مؤتمر لطلبه بلاد اسيا
وافريقيا
واستلمنا دعوه مثل اتحادات الطلبه
لتمثيل همم اتحاد الطلبه الجزائريين اثنين
محمد بن يحيى الله يرحمه اللي وكان رئيس
فرع الجزائر من الاتحاد
وبالعيد عبد السلام الله يرحمه كان يعني
الحقيقه طالب بارز في الحركه الطلابيه هنا
لكن عبد السلام على طول قال انا مش قادر
اروح
فكم يعني اختياري انا بدل عن
الجبهه التحرير اتصلوا بينا وقالوا يعني
طيب احنا نساعدكم في السفر بس بشرط انه
الناس اللي تبعتوهم بره لانه احنا محتاجين
ناس
لتعزيز الصفوف التمثيل التمثيل الثوره في
الخارج
في الجبهه وحملت على عاتقه كحلم الثوره
لكن على النقيض او جانب الاخر كان بعض
اقاربك امامك مثلا يعملون مع سلطات
الاحتلال في ذات الوقت انت كنت متواجد في
باريس وفرنسا البلد المحتل
لبلدك الجزائر كيف كنت تعاين هذا الامر
اللي حصل يوم اول نوفمبر 54 ما بقاش فيه
ناس مع الفرنساويين وناس ضد الفرنساويين
انا عمي شقيق والدي قتلوه فرنساويين سنه
57 لانه بيته كان مستعمل الجيش التحرير
كمركز
الرقيه الشرعيه ويناموا فيه ويساعدهم على
تجنيد الناس قتلو هو قريب اخر ايضا كان
عنده منصب في الاداره الفرنسيه وابناء عمي
كثيرين جدا قتلوا او اعتقلوا
وبعضهم نظم الى جيش التحرير وقتل في صفوف
جيش التحرير يعني
بعض الاقاليم
الحركه انضموا الى الحركه
بعضهم متطوع وبعضهم مجبر
[موسيقى]
132 عاما من الاحتلال كنيستها سواعد
الثوار في معارك داميه استمرت 18 اعوام
لتشرق شمس الجزائر في العالم برحيل
الاستعمار في الخامس من يوليو من العام
كيف استقبلت هذا الاعلان الحرب
كانت الامل عالي جدا
ومراحل يعني كان كنا قريبين من الياس
وبالتالي عندما تم الاتفاق مع الفرنساويين
على انهم قبلوا بشروطنا
طبعا بالنسبه لنا كان حلم تحقق
وممكن بعض الاوقات فكرنا الان
لن نرى هذا اليوم في حياتنا
الفرنسيين للخروج من الجزائر والقبول
بالشروق
الشعب الجزائري على انه
بعد الان 122 سنه
قامت مظاهرات شعبيه
عامه بدات في الجزائر العاصمه رئيس جمهور
وبعض المقربين خلاص خلينا نتفاهم مع
الجزائر
احنا انتصارنا كان اكبر من انتصار عسكري
في الداخل في الخارج يعني استطعنا على
اننا نجلد الجزء الاكبر من العالم ضدهم
جيش التحرير في الداخل ما في شيء لانه تعب
همم لكن الشعب الجزائري
اقل من الاستقلال الكامل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الجزائر
في القاهره طبعا في عهد الرئيس احمد بالله
في مارس عام 1963 من وقفه وراء قرار
تعيينك
رئيس
وزير خارجيه كان محمد كريستيانو الله
يرحمه همم
جمال عبد الناصر هل كان يستمع اليك بشان
احوال الجزائر
علاقتنا مع الدوله المصريه كانت عن طريق
المخابرات المصريه وهذا شيء طبيعي انه
كانت علاقات سريه وسلاح وفلوس بعد
الاستقلال المخابرات استمرت في محاونتها
لانه هي تسيطر على علاقه مع الجزائر فانا
الكلام اللي قلت له الرئيس عبد الناصر
الانقلاب عليه رغبه العسكر في السيطره على
الحكم فجاه
يكون البديل المفضل
تصحيح فوري بعدين يعني هذول مش عسكر
بالمعنى التقليدي كانوا في قياده الثوره
وتقدري تقول على انهم كانوا مدنيين بلباس
عسكري يعني نستطيع ان اقول سنه 65
الناس اللي كان لهم دور على على مستويات
مختلفه كانوا ناس في جيش التحرير وناس في
السجن الخارج
وفي الخلافات
المؤسفه التي يعني اندلعت مباشره بعد
الاستقلال
وبومدين
تحالف
وما في شيك على انه بفضل العسكر تاهو ساعه
في التغلب على زملائه
وبالتالي وصوله الى سده الرئاسه كان فيها
فضل كبير جدا ولهذا فهوين وزير الدفاع
ونائب رئيس وزراء وبالتالي يعني
التغيير
حصل
داخل النظام الجديد الذي همم
بعد الاستقلال
مثلت الجزائر نقطه ارتكاز في مسيره
الابراهيميه نحو فهم اعمق للصراعات حول
العالم
ليمسك بيديه اوراق الحل لبعض الازمات
الكبرى فكان المايسترو الذي نظم اتفاق
الطائفي واخرجه الى النور في لبنان في
العام 1989
كانت عام
1988 تقول بانك نجحت في ابراهيم
هل انت مقتنع بهذا الكلام
يعني حدادنا من القناه همم
هو اجى تكميله
لاتفاقات كثيره عقدوها اللبنانيه في ما
بينهم كان في قبول بمبدا اننا لازم ننتقل
من الطائفيه الى شيئا فشيئا نصل الى الغاء
الطائفيه اللي حصل ان الرئيس اللي اتفقوا
عليه في الطائف
تم اغتياله بايام قليله بعد احتفال بعيد
الاستقلال رئيس اخر اللي هو الياس الهراوي
الاخوه في سوريا
اخذوا الايه الصحراوي بعد انتخابه الى
دمشق وعقدوا معه اتفاقات عده لا اعتقد
انها كانت متمشيه معها
والاهم باكثر من ذلك احنا يعني لجنه
ثلاثيه كان في قرار لاننا نواكب التنفيذ
واذا به بعد سنه واحده تم اشتياح الكويت
من قبل العراق
اتناسى لبنان سوريا
مشيت مع الامريكان
في موضوع تحرير الكويت
وبالتالي يعني ما حدش بقى يتكلم على موضوع
مثلا يعني
في كلام
السوري تدريجيه
السوريه
ولكن هذا هذا الطائر هو اتفاق بين
لبنانيين على امام بطلبوا يقتلوا بعضهم
بعض
[تصفيق]
ثاني بعتها اماميه لك كانت لجنوب افريقيا
عام
1933 حيث نظام الفصل العنصري حدثنا عن هذه
التجربه وكيف كان لقائك بنالسو مانديلا
كان تحدث 27
ابريل 94 لكن تحضير لهذه الانتخابات كانت
عمليه صعبه ومعقده
والمتطرفين البيض كانوا مهددين على بانه
سيمنعوا هذه الانتخابات كنا خايفين على
الانتخابات هذه ما تعقلش او انها تفشل
فعلا ظروف سيئه صعبه يعني التوترات كبيره
جدا محاولات هذول البيض في همم تهكير الجو
من الانتخابات نجحت فيها اماكن كثيره لكن
تم الانتخابات
واتفقوا على انه كيف راح تكون نتائج
بطرس خالي وانا ما شفناه وبالتالي احنا
قبلنا هذه النتائج على ما كان فيها من
مناطق وبالتالي نجاح الانتخابات كان بفضل
قيادات جنوب افريقيا وخاصه همم الرئيس
حكيم
وقوي في نفس الوقت
تيوب 1
زرت افغانستان الاولى كانت عام 1997 وقد
اخفقت فيها والثانيه في العام 2001 وقد
اوجدتم فيها نظام سياسي انهار مؤخرا كيف
تقيم تجربتك في كابول
افغانستان
هذه
التنظمات نزلت من الجبال او رجعت من
الخارج الى افغانستان
وبدات
تحارب بعضها بعض تقريبا من اول يوم
وبالتالي يعني كان في حرب اهليه
متعدده الاطراف وبعدين طلع شيء اسمه
طالبها وانا رجعت مجلس الامن وقلت له يعني
انا استعمل كل ما اعرف
مش كل المسائل اللي اعرفها
ما وصلناش النتيجه لماذا لانه انتم اللي
بعثتوني هناك
ماهيدتونيش بالقدر الكافي
لانه افغانستان بلد بعيد فقير مغلوب على
امره
والاهتمام
بعضهم بعد خليهم لكن انتم غلطانين
هذا راح ينفجر في وجهكم
وهذا اللي حصل في 2001
شعبي وانا اسناد من امريكا
وسقط في نهايه الوتر
بطابور شعبي واسع جدا جدا
النظام السياسي ما كان موفق
نهار الوضع مع الاسف الشديد
وطالبان رجعوا للسلطان وحكومه الطالبان
مسيطره على الوضع في كل مكان
في المقابل وافقت على ان تكون كمبعوث اممي
في العراق بعد الغزو في العام 2003
التعاون الاحتلال
انا اعدلت الاحتلال وانا موظف الامم
المتحده ورئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في
افغانستان
الواحد يقبل مهمه لانها سهله
الامريكان احتلوا العراق بدون
موافقه الامم المتحده ضد راي الامم
المتحده في يونيو 2003
من مجلس الامن بانهم هم والانجليز حكام
العراق
ومجلس الحكم الذي شكل في ذلك الوقت من 15
واحد عراقي
نحن الان قررنا ان نسترجع
سياده العراق للعراق لكن لن نستطيع ان
نقوم بذلك بدون مساعد
ونحن نريد فلان هو اللي يقول هذه العمره
ما كان يمكن ان يقول
الامم المتحده يطلب منها انها تساعد على
ان الدوله تستعيد سيادتها وتقول له لا
يمكن
الحمد لله
طيب هذا سيء
استعاده
يعني انا قمت بدور لانه العراق اصبح عنده
حكومه
الى الامم المتحده
عادت الى جامعه الدول العربيه
نحو سوريا في العام 2012
وتشكل خطر
على الشعب السوري
وعلى المنطقه كلها بل وعلى العالم من
العراق الى سوريا الجغرافيا واحده لكن
الازمه مختلفه
لم تملك الامل بحل الصراع السوري في العام
شو قلت له لازم
تقبلت عام 2014
الابراهيمي لاصلاح
جامعه الدول العربيه
في الوقت نبيل العربي صديق طلب مني ان
اعتذر
لتقديم بعض الاقتراحات على انه كيف يتحسن
عمل العمل العربي قدمنا هذه الاقتراحات
لكن الوضع العربي كان يعني
مثل العاده مجلس الجامعه قال ايه والله
هذا ممتازه
يعني
ما حصلش الوضع العربي الان
لا يوجد تعاون بين الدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
من تطورات الازمه السياسيه هناك هل كنت
تعارض تغيير الرئيس بوتفليقه او بصيغه
اخرى دعني اقول بانك كنت ضد حراك
شيء جميل
لا
يرشح نفسه لولايه خمسه رئيس بوتفليقه وهذا
علم يقين
كان لا يريد ان يرشح نفسه لولايه 55
حتى انت مريض يعني انت احسن من غيرك
[موسيقى]
الاخوان
هل يمكن ان يساعد على انه يعني ترجع
المياه الى مجاريها
التي هي احسن تقول انها كانت تجربه جميله
وتجربه تدرس ولا اخره لكنك ايضا عندما
تكلمت مع الحراك يعني
حضرت مظاهري الجزائر من عباره رحلوا جميعا
يعني طيب هذه يعني عباره شاب يعني عباره
جميله جدا لكن كيف كيف تتم 14 15 مليون في
الشارع كيف رايحين يستلموا الشرطه هذا هو
قصدي
يعني خلاص
الان كيف
وينها الخطوه الاولى
التي نبني بها همم النظام الجديد
بانك تكون رئيسا ههه
رئيسا للجزائر الجزائر
1993 في فبراير لما استقلت قلت انا يعني
قدمت اللي بقدر عليه
اخطاته يوما ويعني وثقتهما
خدمت بلادك يعني فحق الوصول لهذا المنصب
حق مشروع
بوتفليقه وانا كنا كيف نتكلم
هذا الكلام بيناتنا يوما واحدا هو كان
يعرف على ان استقالتي في سنه 93 كانت جديه
وانا كانت
الجزائر ارتفعتها اكتفيت من السياسه
من السياسه في الجزائر بكل تاكيد لكان انا
بحاول اني اتابع ما يجري في هذا الدواليا
لا ازال يعني شارك في مؤتمر هذا في
محاضرات في
لقاءات معنا ناس
[موسيقى]
المصادفه وحدها جماعه بين الابراهيمي
وابنه قبطان سفينه كرواتيه حب الجزائر
ايضا رسخ هذه العلاقه العاطفيه لتتكلم
بالزواج ان مثل في بلاد الشام يقول ما
الذي جمع الشامي بالمغرب لكن هنا اقول ما
الذي يجمعنا الذي جمع الجزائري في
الكرواتيه
[موسيقى]
كان في جيش الجيش الملكي في غزلان قبل
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الملك هرب بعد
احتلال يوصل بها في مركب
والدها كان من ضباطه
والاسكندريه بعدها يعني
اتعرف على الرئيس الله يرحمه
ونظم
الثوره الجزائريه
اهل الجزائر عن طريق في رحله اخرى
مماثله
الفرنساويين او الاسرائيليين اغرق وباخره
وهو استشهد في هذا في هذه الحادث 63
بالله قال لي لازم تروح تشوف ارمله صديقي
وجميله
احد شهداء حرب التحرير
في اسكندريه ولازم تشوفها هي وبنتها رئيس
بلديه فيما بعد قال جده هذا لانه كلفني
بهذه المقرفه المهمه على امل
انه يحصل علاقه بيني وبين بنت صديقه
هكذا
في مصر وتعلمت هناك اللغه العربيه ايوه
كيف وجدتي الاقامه في مصر انا اتولدت في
اسكندريه
فكده حاجه عادي اه لما همم جاءت الثوره
همم اللغه العربيه كانت حاجه ان اي واحد
حتى الاجانب كانوا لازم
يعلموها
بينك وبين الاخضر الابراهيمي عندما يعني
نويت الزواج يعني فروقات ثقافيه لما تعرفت
بك كنت متحمس انا اعرف رجل اشترك في
الثوره كمان كنا عندنا امل اللي عايزين
نبنيه بلد جديد دوله جديده بعد الاستقلال
زواج شوف ال 64 يعني لليوم كم سنه 58 سنه
ما شاء الله 58 سنه كيف حافظته على هذا
الزواج قرار
مهم جدا
الواحد ما يقبلش عليه بسهوله كله دقيقه هي
الشغل
في العراق
يعني ما هم مره كنت قلت لها انه يا اخي
انتم شو بتعمل في العراق قالت لي طيب انت
تتكلم من افغانستان
وخايف عليه في العراق
نجم عن هذا التهاني العلاقه طبعا الزواج
وكنت انت متردد شوي في الموافقه
يعني مش سهله لانه الواحد يوافق على
الزواج بنته من اي حد انا كنت باعرفه
بعرفه الله
[موسيقى]
زواج مسؤوليه
ولا شيء يعني
هو بيقول على انه كان خائف اني اقول
لكن هو واخوه الملك عبد الله هنا صارت
خطبه عن الطريقه التقليديه
وقلنا يعني مبروك وربنا يسهل ما اصعب
اللحظات التي مرت عليكم
كان اصعب وقت
واخضر وقت كان في كل يوم قنابل وحاجات ضده
كنت بخاف الم تخشى من الاغتيال
الى لبنان لكن لما اوصل هناك خلاص
كنت اخاف كثير جدا
ههه
تعلمت الصبر انت ماذا تعلمت منها
[ضحك]
مشاكل كثيره مش مش بناتنا وانما في حياتنا
[موسيقى]
هل تحاول ان تزرع بعض القيام في احفادك
تتواصل معهم بشكل دائم
لما اشوفهم
دائما
انا احاول وهم يحاولون اننا نتكلم
بشيء من الجنه
20 سنه قربت على 21
[موسيقى]
لم تتخرج من معهد العلوم السياسيه في
باريس لكن اهدوك دكتوره فخريه وطلب منك ان
تقوم بتدريس الجيل الجديد في المعهد يعني
اول ماذا تعني لك هذه
الخطوه وبماذا كنت تحاول وتحاول ان تزرع
في الجيل الذي تقوم بتدريسه
انتم احسن منك بكثير
اولا متعلمين احسن منك
احنا يعني
قليل من اللي تخرج احسن لنا ترك الدراسه
في السنه الثانيه في السنه الثالثه في
السنه الرابعه ما خلصت
ثانيا يعني بدانا العمل يعني بالنسبه
للجزائر على الخاص يعني في الدوله
ارتكبنا اخطاء كثيره
اشياء كثير متعلمناش مكانش حد حد علمنا
اقول الشباب هذا انتم هلا يعني في من
يعلمكم وبالتالي ما فيش شيء يخوفهم يعني
يقدروا ينجزوا ينجزناه اكثر
عندنا شويه ثقه في النفس خلي تكون عندنا
اراده حقيقيه علم على يعني الاقدام
والانجاز
والعمل مع بعض مش العمل ضد بعض
داخل البلد الواحد وداخل المنطقه العربيه
كلها
الدرس الاهم الذي تعلمه الاخضر الابراهيمي
وانت تقترب من عمبك 90 يعني
هروره العمل من اجل سلام لكن شاءت الاقدار
لانه كنت تقريبا طول حياتي قريب من الحروب
في من اجل الخروج من هذه الحروب
والوصول الى سلام احنا في منطقه ما هل
القضيه الفلسطينيه لن يحترم منا احد
اذا كان احنا فرطنا
في هذه القضيه وفي هذا الشهر
ممكن يحترم انما ما قالوا لنا ناس تحترمك
اكثر لما يكون الواحد عنده حد ادنى من
الالتزام
مبادئ لاخلاق نحن منطقه عربيه فلسطين
الشعب الفلسطيني
بنظر الى الحياه
[موسيقى]
الى مسارات
طريقي مع الاخضر الابراهيمي انتهى لكنني
ساكمل الطريقه متراقبه اللقاء شخص اخر مع
جانب اخر جديد
[موسيقى]